[Musique]
c'est un grand jeu en effet aujourd'hui
pour la première fois je suis heureux de
vous montrer mon cul à la télévision
la blague est célèbre et elle perdu vous
monsieur le maire accompagné de ses
adjoints et de ses conseillers
municipaux a bien voulu nous recevoir et
je m'aperçois que vous êtes bien
chauffer puisque voici le fameux poil le
cheval en
1976 dans l'émission le petit rapporteur
l'humoriste daniel prévost s'en donner à
coeur joie on arrive dans une petite
ruelle j'ai l'impression que mon cul est
très étroit
voilà comment montcuq c'est la bonne
prononciation est entré dans l'histoire
quarante six ans plus tard la ville est
toujours sous les projecteurs le célèbre
village du lot accueille le pop corn
festival du nom de l'émission phare de
twitch quatre mille festivaliers sont
attendus je respire à pleins poumons
l'air parce que c'est vrai que
abu de l'air pur de monter à ici c'est
très sain en fait très bonne figure
après le passage de daniel prévost la
ville a attiré les curieux premiers
témoins de cette notoriété l'ancien
garde champêtre du village soit il ya eu
deux personnes avaient alors de pouvoir
la vierge et car-pass a donné plein dans
les rues de montcuq pour acheter surtout
des cartes postales
et pour les journalistes aussi toutes
les occasions sont bonnes pour faire un
stop à montcuq toujours en 1994 le tour
de france passait par là et ça en
inspirer certains
aujourd'hui c'est un grand jour pour la
deuxième fois à la télévision je vais
vous montrer mon
au fil des ans montcuq assoit sa
renommée au point d'être pressenti pour
faire son entrée sur le plateau du
monopoly en 2007 le maire assure l
opération de com pour ôter vraiment que
pour le monopoly
aujourd'hui nous avons deux ennemis à la
race par rapport à la carte
bon finalement dunkerque est choisi mais
d'autres flairent le bon filon
commercial bavoirs t-shirt montcuq fait
vendre parfois même des objets
improbables comme ici en 2013 le fruit
son beau humer l'air de montcuq et le
mettre en boîte c'est la petite
entreprise d'antoine de blake en jeu
capture faire attention qui serait
chaque pas avant que le continent soit
bien remplie l'air de montcuq est
toujours à vendre
l'objectif du maire de 1976 est atteint
je vais vous avez l'air d'aimer
profondément mon cul oh oui où ça
monsieur j'aime n'ont pu et si vous
saviez comme je suis heureux de voir
prospérer
comme je serais heureux de voir
s'agrandir si vous voulez mon taf un
ballon à venir et bien rompue et des
blagues
[Musique]